[Music]
guys my guest today
mr johnny christ from event sevenfold
and also host of his own podcast drinks
with johnny thank you for making the
drive oh yeah man thank you i know that
was a bit of a stretch it wasn't too bad
i haven't been out of the house in a
while so it was kind of nice to drive
yeah you kind of just been chilling yeah
for like four years yeah just like in
the house wait because when we when was
your last tour we got off the road in
the summer of 2018. okay we were
supposed to do a uh profits of rage tour
um well with that main support and our
vocalist uh shadows
ended up having some issues with his
vocal cords so we were all good to
cancel that one so
and you know we're intending on getting
our record done and putting it out and
then a pandemic kid yeah it was like hey
what's up
well there's no real rush now so we just
kind of been taking our time on that
record and uh getting it all done i mean
we we worked on it pretty much
immediately like we usually do
but you know we took a little bit more
time a little bit more effort you know
there's
of course countless um uh uh delays in
the process right now yeah because of
the pandemic because of everything
everything just everyone's go everyone's
lost their goddamn minds and is this the
longest you've like chilled since you've
been in started uh being in the band
this is the longest i haven't had a had
a working job since i was 18 years old
like literally i i thought about it
like each day that like passes i'm like
[ __ ] man i've never been home for this
long yeah like almost luckily i have
created the show right before all this
[ __ ] are you 36 i'm 37 now 37 37.
we're only a few years apart yeah i'll
be 35 this year or this year i'll be 35
on
sunday
it's your [ __ ] birthday on sunday
and you didn't even
realize it
that's
amazing oh my god well happy birthday i
know i don't know like it's so
obviously the world has just [ __ ] up
our [ __ ] calendars it shows what that
is so i'm like oh wait [ __ ] that's
[ __ ] sunday birthday yeah i'll be 35
man
yeah i know here it goes dude dude
what's uh
what's cool about the way we met we met
i was doing a show
in huntington beach
with trevor wallace right and you
know but you already knew trevor wallace
yeah yeah we had uh on season one of
drinks with johnny uh we had trevor come
by the house um and he was on the he was
on an episode that we were filming
in person yeah everything well i mean
that was the
i don't even plan on making this a
podcast to be honest it was a it was an
avenged sevenfold youtube channel thing
we just realized that we had like all
the rights to our youtube channel uh
back and we were like
all right let's start making content on
it that seems like the thing to do
and i threw in the idea of doing some
you know drinks and hanging out with
some people yeah
yeah totally and it's a very chill
podcast and i had no idea though that
someone else brought it up to me and
they're like you should do this as a
podcast i said what the [ __ ] is a
podcast because i had no idea like i
mean i knew the name of podcast heard
joe rogan all those kind of things but i
didn't really know no
i didn't know the world i didn't know
like how vast it was too and how many
people had podcasts and the varying uh
categories just like music and i was
like okay this is this is actually
pretty cool it's it's such a free space
right like you get literally and you're
really good at it no thank you for not
really knowing that world and or you
know coming from that world you're
pretty good at it thank you i had a good
time i had a good time on your show man
and uh but uh
you know
one thing i had learned about you
that i found out
you're a val kilmer fan big time
man
big time this whole podcast might be
valkyrie
all right oh that's right i forgot we
were talking about this when you're on
the show that's right yeah uh uh well we
did talk about this we did a little bit
a little bit a little bit not a lot yeah
cause because you you're you um
correct me very wrong you started
getting
into like really loving the world of
acting not necessarily doing it yourself
but just appreciating the art form
absolutely yeah yeah and you mentioned
val kilmer being one of your
yeah i mean in like high school that's
when i realized like i like had an
appreciation for real talented actors
yeah and he's one of them i mean just i
mean two of my all-time favorite roles
of his is uh playing jim morrison and
and black holiday you know so i mean
i i used to get high in high school and
watch the doors dude over and over give
me that so many times so many times that
i actually would be like hi with my
buddies i'm like i don't know which
one's more like jim morrison anymore
dude because he did such an amazing job
[ __ ] insane
and gave credit and give credit to the
move the filmmakers of that too yes
in the limelight too
and really getting the angles i mean he
we they put pictures to pictures he
looked like that was i think it was
before he did tombstone
it might have what year was it did we
have it it was earlier
i think i want to say
tombstone was might have been
93. he was like 93 yeah yeah and that
was oh yeah 91 yeah that was before
let's see if i'm right about if we're
right about tombstone
tombstone i saw in the theaters on
christmas day with my fans you saw it in
theaters christmas day it was it came
out on christmas day see 93 i think i
was uh okay so it says 24th that's
because it came out at midnight the
night before i'm not wrong i saw it
though
it was december 25th [ __ ] isn't
it funny how you got to do that because
we're like someone's going to get in
there and be like actually it came out
if you did not johnny johnny is
completely wrong [ __ ] guys
that was also how old was i then i would
have been 93 so i was born in 84 so that
would have put who could do mathematics
i was six
i was six i was nine years old yeah i
was six in
great wait so you'll be 38 this year
uh yeah november at the end of this year
i just oh you just started 37. oh okay
so we're yeah what's that four years i'm
not doing math [ __ ] it i'm not i'm not
doing that
i'm not doing too early for that i know
it's too [ __ ] early
it's just i mean i i got you always
recording this early like like never
i only did uh this early for you because
i figured cause you were coming so far
and i was like i'd rather him get out
here early to where he doesn't have to
like leave late because well you got me
at a good time anyway because i'm not
drinking this month so like i could
actually drive no drunk no drunk january
or i do dry your weary dry
i still get high
but i don't i don't drink
well because for me like i mean other
people might have a different opinion
but uh i think i have my drinking under
control it's not that's not why i don't
drink during this month it's because i
usually have put on about 20 pounds over
the holidays uh-huh so i need to just
[ __ ] all the way and like you don't get
any calories from weed no you don't you
could eat a bunch but like you could do
edibles oh yeah i do edibles you can
handle edibles a lot i mean that's where
i started i wish i would have brought
them dude
i would [ __ ] cry on edibles i said
have you tried the lagunitas hi-fi hops
since i'm a drinker i like drinking
it's an edible it's like a beer but it's
just sparkling water so it's zero
calories and they infuse the thc and it
it tastes kind of like a
lighter ipa oh so it's the taste of it
it's not alcohol in it there's no
alcohol in it oh it's just a taste of
that so it's zero calories
that might give me the wagon if i did
that
and they have different milligrams so
you could start with like a two
milligram go to a five go to a ten i'll
you know when i'm out golfing i'll start
off with like a five you can function oh
[ __ ] yeah
on an edible ah absolutely
i think people that can do that are
[ __ ] insane
really cause i got a buddy i mean like
well i don't even consider myself that
big of a stoner like i don't know it's
not like i even do it all the time i
just like i don't know four days ago at
the same time nyquil freaks me out so
okay yeah just to give you guys
just to keep
i'm always like that's like my wife my
wife can't do anything either she like
she [ __ ] does she drink it all she
drinks yeah she drink not too heavy
though i mean i mean
she's comparing herself to me so no she
doesn't drink that but you seem like i
couldn't imagine you being like like if
you were drunk i wouldn't imagine it'd
be like
a like shown
you know what i mean i got my producer
over here laughing at his ass oh really
am i wrong no so what i'll i'll be
honest yes you're wrong but there is
but there's a point there's it comes to
a point because for the most part i i
actually believe because i
not tooting my own horn and kids don't
think that this is something to brag
about but i have a really high tolerance
when i'm drinking like really
ridiculously to the point where
uh guys of your size are even bigger i
can hang with you and drink it yeah i'll
drink those [ __ ] but as soon as
they're done about 15 minutes later i
black out and then it's very apparent
but up until that point you don't know
until i'm gone and that's the okay yeah
so like no that's fine i have a
threshold that i work on every day
what is your dream
a choice all of it
[Laughter]
i'm mostly a wine and scotch guy when
i'm like when i uh
night for lounging and stuff like that
but like out and about i love a good ipa
um those cocktails are great i mean i
love some old-timey cocktails i got them
old-fashioned yeah old-fashioned is good
i like doing i like mixing those up
though because get like a standard
old-fashioned you could do like a
vanilla one you could do like a bunch of
different [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
i just did wild turkey wild turkey just
in general yeah just in general yeah
this which is hey when did you start
drinking 14.
i thought you didn't drink yeah i've
been drinking
almost eight years that's what i was
okay that's what i was like oh you mean
before okay
like last week you had one man what was
the invite like you're gonna
[Laughter]
no yeah yeah i started drinking at 14
first thing i ever got drunk off of was
uh wild turkey and also the last thing i
got drunk off of so i stuck with it
forever it was good i was married to
that one yeah well turkey's good i
suppose
people would think i was crazy whenever
i would like
did you have it straight yeah
okay that's a little weird that
especially at 14. but uh you know what i
would have worked on 14 though well when
i was 14 you'd get get someone to get
you like one of the little half pints or
pints of wild turkey from the liquor
store yeah and go into the bowling alley
get a dr pepper mix it into one of those
big bladder busters yeah roll some balls
and get drunk i don't like the i don't
like the mixed drinks
yeah it's the it's the sugar because one
i don't really drink soda i don't do
that
give me that wild turkey baby
yeah i remember i remember the day uh
the day it happened we were
it was a bunch of homies that i skated
with and
one of our buddies had a brother who was
uh way older than him he was old enough
to buy alcohol obviously and we were
like yeah get us get us something
surprise us you know what because we
didn't know we was like get us whatever
yeah and he brought wild turkey and that
that changed my life
and uh for for good and bad for good and
bad
yeah i used to just pour that [ __ ] in
the cup and just drink it like i was
wild with it i mean yeah it'll put a
little hair on your chest
oh yeah you know what i mean it's
whiskey it's whiskey [ __ ] around the
whiskey is not [ __ ] around no no you
know it's good stuff though but you like
how how were you on the road with it
though when like you go on tour oh dude
i'm a sloppy mess really no uh i try to
keep it you know i am but probably
yeah well dude early on through like
early 20s i mean there's a couple of
times when the other band mates have to
tell me can't drink before the shows
buddy oh really yeah i'd just play like
[ __ ] you know it was it wasn't just me
like our guitar players we we used to
like record from the consoles and listen
back to them like when we were back in
the band days like when we were driving
ourselves into vans yeah we're on warp
tours and stuff we're like i wonder what
we sounded like like it sounded pretty
cool so you guys were recording yourself
yeah just from the concept oh okay it's
like our live thing like yeah so it's
not it's not very accurate it's not
mixed for it or anything like that oh
okay i was thinking you had like back in
the day with cds man you had to burn it
right on a cd and then go throw it in
the van and listen to it to the next
place just to see what yeah just to see
what we needed to work on and a couple
of times we quickly realized we needed
to work on everything because we were a
few of us were drinking a little too
much before the show so then we we
implemented a a thing where we stopped
uh
all drinking before shows yeah and then
you know it wasn't drinking during the
show but then quickly came back and then
like i'll go on on stage
first two songs i'll play sober and then
i'll start drinking wine
and then go throughout the night and
then but i mean you're so up you're
playing at like 10 o'clock sometimes
even later yeah you're up till you're up
till four o'clock in the morning even if
you're
doing a chill night yourself that's
interesting that you guys would listen
back to see how you guys uh earlier
and then i think it's interesting that
you say that because when i think of you
guys you guys are really like
and
i mean you guys are really [ __ ]
talented musicians no thanks man you
know like
there's so many bands out there but like
not everyone in the band like your whole
band is talented as [ __ ] you know what i
mean like you guys are all like really
really [ __ ] good and is that does
that come from like just listening back
like that i mean i think it just comes
from uh
practice and pride yeah yeah um
the fact that we are i mean we always
push each other too like i mean every
album
people always like a lot of people ask
when i'm in a discord or something like
that when we're interacting with fans
like what's the hardest song to play
live what's what was the hardest most
difficult song like by the time i get to
play and i'm live i've already practiced
it so many times
second nature yeah
but i will say there's at least three to
four songs per album that are paid in
the ass for me to track knowing that
like i'm going to have to play those
parts and like because you write those
parts right and you go like this is
going to be hard to actually track
and then once you figure out how to
track it then you got to relearn how to
actually play it standing up doing all
that stuff so it's different levels of
difficulty on all of it so comedy i just
gotta i just got to go to a bar show and
[ __ ] eat dicks until i get the joke
right
but that's your practice you know
whatever you like that's what i have to
practice in front of people have to
watch me that's actually worse yeah
that's worse
i'm in my room by myself and [ __ ]
hacking away for a long time before
anyone could go oh here it goes let's
try this new one
that's gotta be nerve-wracking i mean it
can be but at the same time like after
you've done it you get used to it that
you get comfortable with like knowing
it's gonna
eat a bag of dicks you know what i mean
i do mean that strongly because
you know sometimes like when you think
it in your head or like some people when
they write it down you're like damn
that's that's funny and then you go out
and say you go
what the [ __ ] did i even say like you
just don't even like it was like oh and
it forces you
to find the clarity do you ever uh i'm
sorry to interrupt there but
you think do you ever record yourself
and like see like what worked and what
didn't like you're just saying like you
may not you might actually stumble upon
a joke while you're while you're testing
stuff that went over well that you
didn't actually write do you ever go
back and use that or anything you know
what you know what's insane i have a
really good memory okay my memory is
[ __ ] out of this world when it comes
to like that stuff
so i just remember
see i don't have to record it no i don't
some people do you know what i mean but
like also if it if it was uh
if i i i told myself this if i can't
remember it then it probably wasn't that
good
okay you know that's that's i forget a
lot of things though so you do yeah i'd
be like if i if i didn't have it written
down or recorded i mean my voice notes
on my phone is just
it's full oh really everything yeah
you're just walking around you know and
i have an idea for a riff sing it into
there go see if it was actually any good
a couple days later oh you can sing it
and then you can go and play it yeah
how the [ __ ] you do that what are you a
robot no
i've been doing this since i was 12
years old
it's just this beautiful thing no no
it's never a beautiful day
just because i could sing it and replay
it doesn't mean it was any good yeah
that's fair that's fair yeah so yeah
when did you you because uh
when did you start playing music not not
in the band uh i started playing music i
got my first uh instrument when i was 12
years old it was a bass guitar that was
my first uh instrument that i owned i
played my dad's guitar a little bit
before and the family keyboard in the
corner a little bit okay that was all
just dealing with one time family like
from a musical background no not at all
they just we just don't know so how did
you discover it i'm always curious about
how like people discover music and get
so locked into it and like like
basically yeah what made you say yes to
music and then embracing it and enjoying
it i think music was always
so our our house was never like a full
of musician house but music appreciation
for sure it was listed all the time you
know uh my and i had it from
two different genres right off the bat
my mom was very into the pop world in
the 80s and 90s and my father was very
much into heavy metal um metallica ac dc
mega death all those things so when i
was in the car with my dad we listened
to hard rock and jimi hendrix i forgot
to mention that one led zeppelin all
those things uh sabbath that was in my
dad's astro van in my mom's minivan we
listened to michael jackson the bengals
like a bunch of like that was her world
that was her world she was also aerobics
teacher and oh if i was
you know when i was a toddler uh before
i went into kindergarten um if we
couldn't find a sitter a daycare of some
kind i would sit in the corner while she
was teaching aerobics classes yeah in
the corner in the mirror listening to
the the pop songs that they were dancing
to doing the robux things and i would be
over there dancing and doing you're all
about it yeah and then as soon as soon
as i noticed that the other ladies were
noticing and laughing and i was getting
attention for it oh that was done like
it was a wrap i i ate it up like like
crazy so
i think because of that because i had
positive influence from listening to
music um it was just always something
that was that i gravitated towards yeah
and then
i think it was like in fifth grade and
one of my buddies was like
kind of joking kind of serious he was
like my dad has a drum kit i'm going to
pull out of the
out of the ceiling and i'm going to
start a band you want to be a part of it
i was like i got a keyboard at home and
he's like that's cool you should
probably learn bass though and i was
like all right
i mean and i loved cliff burton and duff
mckagan at the time they're two of my
favorites and then of course uh matt
freeman so yeah yeah you got some great
ones to look up to
or like that you've discovered yeah
where you were like damn that's that's
[ __ ] good
it's funny enough is i didn't realize it
when i was listening to music as a kid
but i did
i had an ear for listening to different
bass players you know not everyone has
that and i didn't realize it until later
like a lot of people don't even know
what the bass is doing in a song you
know like someone who's not
musically inclined or into music or
anything yeah they wouldn't know i
wouldn't know they you feel it you know
it's there if i was to take it away you
would know that something's missing but
you might not be following the bass
player or the bass lines that are
happening yeah i can always the base
makes it sound full
yeah for most people it just fills in
yeah but if you're really if if you're
listening for it you can hear all the
notations and what's going on the uh a
really good basis like a flea or a clay
pool or something like that it's really
playing off of a kick drum pattern and
adding notation to it that really melds
between the drums and the guitar there's
like a lot of nuances that you can like
it i'm feeling it right now i'm just
thinking i was thinking about it in my
head
[Laughter]
is that crazy though when you when you
talk about um
i mean your dad listening metallica and
then you [ __ ] play
with metallica that was my first concert
ever it was a telescope it was a
metallica concert on the load tour my
grandfather took me okay um
and what year was that
well load came out in like 95 96 and it
was the first
trip through the forum at the time is
when i saw okay
um corn was main support
that was pretty cool i love corn i'm a
big corn forget who opened might have
been butthole surfers why am i thinking
that no i don't think it was it was
somebody else somebody else then corn
the metallica um was my first show so
and that was the first concert yeah it
was it was pretty rad um
so yeah that was my first introduction
to them live but i mean i listened to
them since pretty much birth yeah i had
been exposed to metallica and then yeah
in
2006 was the first time we did any shows
with them in europe
i got to meet the guys a little bit
there
um went up on stage with them one time
in germany that was like oh it was
june 6 06.
um still remember that uh we were in
berlin and we went up and sing
[ __ ] some punk rock cover now i don't
remember what it was but uh it was like
at the end they invited us up with them
they usually do like misfits covers
don't they they did misfits i think this
one was
uh it'll come back to me it'll come back
to me
[ __ ] because they were doing like
misfits covers like earlier yeah oh yeah
they were all they're all big misfits
and they're all punk fans i mean yeah
from the bay area like
from the bay area in the in the late 70s
80s was was pretty pretty impressive
you're also the punk i love punk yeah i
i grew up so i grew up listening to as
we said earlier hard rock and pop at the
same time and then
later
about when i was approaching my teenage
years i started to get into punk rock i
started hearing uh bands like no facts
rancid magnesium pennywise growing up
here in southern california i mean a lot
of it was weird to me because i just i
just assumed that that's that was going
on everywhere in the country yeah i just
like when you're a kid you're just like
oh [ __ ] punk is so big and everything
yeah you think it's like a big thing and
then you realize it was only here yes
in california
it's
talking to all these people about my
favorite band's rants yeah and no
effects and all of who and i'm like how
do you not know
these guys it's interesting you say that
because i think about when i was a kid
and i knew like a band and i'm like oh
man they're coming to town and i go see
this band and i thought they were like
the biggest band cause i knew about them
and you know to me they were like
this glorious thing and then i go see
them live and there's like
20 people [ __ ]
and i'm like wait what i thought
everybody be here you know it's it's
it's funny that you say that yeah well
then you go back and like uh when
and those were always the biggest dates
for warped tours when they came through
southern california for the most part
they had a couple of east coast ones
that rivaled it as well they were pretty
big but for the most part it was
southern california california dates
were the bigger ones and uh i always
remember that i was like going uh my
brother going to
one of them i was too young to go i have
two older brothers one of them was the
one that got me into punk and he brought
back like a lag wagon cd and he was like
that blew my mind it was right it was
duh
um and then they had a record in between
i don't remember and then they came out
with haas
haas i was a
end of my sixth grade year changed my
[ __ ] life that record was
yeah you you got you got all that like
that 90s like really good stuff mid 90s
mid 90s mid 90s
like really big epitaph was gigantic
everything uh kung fu records around
here like
like everything was like kung fu records
yeah dude escalante dude wow i haven't
heard someone say that forever yeah yeah
wow that just blew my [ __ ] mind yeah
there was all that stuff and there was
all the compilation cds yeah the
crossovers for the different independent
rock labels that were around here
those compilation cds back in the day
were like the [ __ ] thing yeah like
when you got one you were like excited
that's how you discovered bands that's
how you discover yeah of course 100
now they got all the now
the now 55 how many of those [ __ ]
now's they got huh dude my wife i was i
i almost uh divorced her it was before
it was before we got married so i really
couldn't but i knew we were gonna get
married later uh she had a few of those
now cds like when i was like under her
bed like one of the times we were moving
from uh our apartment and i was like why
do you have these yeah and then she was
like but i was like you weren't even
discovering these bands like you that's
pop you knew it yeah yeah yeah everybody
that's the funny thing about those
everyone knows those [ __ ] bands yeah
so now it's been out since what does
that say 97
so they've been making 97 since 97 and
they've been and they have 61 of those
[ __ ] albums
that's a lot
and all it is is just [ __ ] everything
it's just top 40 yes top 40. that's the
easiest thing to release of all time
easiest thing to release
good for them good good good for the
marketing you know what i liked about
those convolutions too they would put
like uh
the deep cuts of bands you know yeah
they would always they usually do two
songs per band yes and it would be there
would be the one that like is there like
they're they're bigger more known song
here's the one to catch you followed up
by the one that's like all right if you
like that you might like this yes yes
that's what i loved about those [ __ ]
damn yeah what a [ __ ] time it was
such a great time for punk rock
and it was so funny because at the time
i'm like 12 13 years old i was thought
about this the other day like i'm 12 or
13 years old and when i'm you know talk
to 18 20 year old guys in the punk rock
scene you go to punk rock show yeah and
there and you tell them the bands that
you're like and you're like no facts
offspring rancid bad religion and at the
time they look at you like well that's
not punk rock
i know and i was like oh i felt like i
felt like i was getting my punk rock
card taken right yeah it was that that
was like the stupidest time i [ __ ] i
hate people like that where they're like
no that's not punk that's not it's like
eat a dick yeah okay eat a [ __ ] dick
but it was so funny that now it's like
what makes it not what are the most
legendary punk bands in the [ __ ] that
are still doing it today like yeah it's
like
i know i know it was in the [ __ ] room
don't realize a lot of the like you're
[ __ ] what you consider punk those
bands were touring with those bands
right you know like before they you know
got any like big success they were
touring with opening for those [ __ ]
bands ransom was out with the ramones
all the time exactly and in [ __ ] uh
like i think when i think of that i
remember specifically was offspring
because you know offspring like got me
like skating and stuff like that like
that's what like i love to skate to but
i remember i wore like a offspring shirt
and i used to hang out with these dudes
that like you know were really big into
like the casualties and stuff like that
which i love those bands too absolutely
but i wore offspring certain they were
like what the [ __ ] are you doing like
why do you like that band do you think
it's still the same way like do people
like
if we were talking to young punk rockers
we'd be like that's not punk rock you
need to listen you know what i i don't
think so because this year's genera i
mean this year's this generation
they pretty much do whatever the [ __ ]
they like because if you if you listen a
lot of that's music now i like that i
love it you know like because like uh
you know
yeah it's just like who who gives a [ __ ]
i think you know as uh time has gone on
people just
honestly say who gives a [ __ ] like
you and i
we both love justin timberlake i love
justin's i [ __ ] love the biggest
justin timberlake and we didn't talk
about this but i discovered this i do
deep dives
yes
i'm a huge fan i've seen him in concert
you've seen me
three times three times i've seen him
he's [ __ ] it's incredible it's
incredible i bet it is the last one i
saw
i want to say was in 2019
he was he was at the forum he was at the
phone for a couple of nights and
uh this was when like the 3d uh
projection stuff was still pretty it was
still brand new uh-huh it's crazy how
fast it's only three years ago and it's
like been overdone already but like they
he had like the walls the white walls
that had like some texture to it that
you could project on it and it made it
look like they were all [ __ ] moving
all over the place and then he has the
stage actually is on wheels stands up
and it's a clear stage all of a sudden
that goes over the entire floor of the
crowd goes to the back he's taking shots
with people in the back still dancing
his ass off and singing and i'm like
what's not to love here yeah that is
[ __ ] amazing i've never i haven't
gotten to see him live but i've always
loved ever since that first album
dropped and and that was like justified
baby yeah justified when that first
album dropped i remember it uh it's
funny because i just had joined
cheerleading i just said yeah
i just thought
it didn't know yeah it was like perfect
and i remember
uh
someone i had cheered with
was playing that album i was like man
this is [ __ ] good
and they're like it's justin timberlake
like the guy from nsync and they're like
yeah i was like he's he does his own
[ __ ] you know what i mean like and
he's better because i didn't even
realize
you know i don't know how
noticeable noticeable he was like in in
sync i mean he probably was like later
on towards the end of there neither
neither was i but my wife again going
back to my wife who shares your last
name her name's lacey
she was a huge boy band fan
through the 90s and
she was like no just she educated me on
this justin was always the standout guy
in insects oh he was he was always the
leader everyone knew he was going to go
on to do other things really according
to according to mike according to yeah
because if she's followed yeah if she's
followed then she follow the whole time
and then but then i go back like she
listens to then sings stuff more she's
obviously justin timberlake yeah as well
but she'll nsync will come on and when
we're listening to like i don't know
siriusxm 2000s or something like that or
whatever station that is and it'll come
up and like then i'd start listening to
it you could
you can hear justin more than the other
guys and i was like oh okay yeah because
he's a young justin but he's still the
one with that you can distinctly take
out his voice from god that makes sense
yeah he's he he's [ __ ]
amazingly talented he plays he plays
guitar his actions his comedy acting
his acting's a great dude and his comedy
okay you you could speak more on this
but like those times that he's been on
snl yeah he's always killed it he kills
it and i see a lot of and no respect to
some of the other actors and singers and
stuff who've done it i haven't seen
someone who's comes from the music world
that good yes that's fair i was like i
think that's pretty he killed it in that
one movie too what was that [ __ ] uh
he he played like a nerdy guy
what was it called with the bad tv bad
teacher yeah with uh you've seen that
you guys ever seen that cameron diaz no
with cameron diaz yeah he plays like
this super nerdy
[Laughter]
yeah so like that yeah that's the same
game but no he he [ __ ] he [ __ ]
kills it that's dope like yeah so so was
that a thing for you because i think for
me as a kid
you know because yeah you had your
friends that were like you know this is
what you know if you're punk it's only
punk but i mean
outside of that i was still listening to
like other stuff because i was just like
yeah i was like i think this is that i'm
like this is good right you know what i
mean well the easy the easy ones was
punk and metal for me you don't get too
much slack yeah you know that's pretty
good yeah but i mean
i remember when aqua was huge we came
out with barbie girl
and everyone just knew barbie goal
i knew the whole album like i love album
oh [ __ ] yeah aquarius aquarium those two
albums are incredible really yeah those
are great okay listen i i listen anytime
i get an album recommendation i'll
always
aquarium and aquarius i mean all of
aqua's pretty because i am going to look
at those two albums
my son is as well
uh yeah
those two albums i highly recommend from
aqua
they just put you in a good mood don't
listen to them thinking like i'm going
to get blown away by the musicianship
yeah yeah it's just like
this is poppy i like it yeah because you
know most of most of the time when when
a
i mean when you think about like a pop
artist that has like a hit like that you
think that's it right you think that's
probably all they have and then you
actually take a [ __ ] listen
to the album and you go [ __ ]
insane the cardigans did that for me too
around the same time really they had
that love me love me song uh-huh and
then there's another one
it's huge it was massive yeah was that
part of austin powers no
no that was when i think about you i
touched myself right or no might have
been part of austin powers now no i
don't remember i can't remember you got
this little computer thing
i can't remember
um no but then there was another song
type of the cardigan
you love me
there's another song on there that's
like actually like really dark and
loungy and i can't remember the name of
it but it's on that same record
that this is a good record of fire that
song is the only one on the on the album
that sounds like no that wasn't on
no i don't think that was on austin
powers yeah
love fool that's the name of it yeah
i love how that's also a thing you you
always say like the chorus when when you
expect it to be the name of the song and
it's not always the case oh you know
what song i'm thinking because it was
around that same time as the cardigans
love me love me it's that madonna song
that was part of austin powers oh
beautiful stranger yeah that's what i
was thinking because it was like mesh
around and i remember
yeah yeah i just remember that period of
time right but uh no i think about that
whenever people
talk to me about oasis
that's we had a conversation yeah
because most people think
champagne supernova right and wonderwall
but
and i and honestly i'm not allowed to
talk about oasis yet until the 100th
episode but you know what
hey what number is this going to be i
don't know
17. you're only 17
you're never you're never going to make
it up you're only on episode 17 and
you're already going like i'm not
supposed to talk about it
you're never going to make it you know
every time i bring up always
i just want to rise out of my chair but
most people just think but that's that's
people
because oasis never
hit that massive in the states right
everywhere else outside of the you know
i mean
they got pretty massive here too you
know but not as big as like
not if they hadn't imploded see i have
this theory if they hadn't imploded they
would have been like the 90s coldplay
yeah like 100 percent yeah and that
because coldplay is still to this day
like they haven't done [ __ ] in a while
but they could still they would just
they'd you two that [ __ ] they just come
out
did you see what they were doing
they announced that they're gonna um
their last album was gonna be recorded
in 2025 i think and it's gonna be their
end their last but they're they're still
gonna tour well yeah they're not gonna
make albums anymore well well we could
get into that too who's gonna be making
albums anymore in short order yeah it's
just that's that doesn't surprise me
it's not that shocking it's kind of like
dude and some people were and i said i
said that's not that shocking i was like
that's actually
pretty music i mean music is making
adjustments right now in in the industry
because for so long the artists and this
goes for creators of all kinds but for
so long that ha
they're not getting paid directly out
for that stuff there's a bunch of people
who are taking a [ __ ] ton of money in
between is everyone i'm always curious
about telling them that like you got all
this success they must be rich they must
be doing all this [ __ ] it's like yeah
i'm sure they're well off don't get me
wrong like no one's hurting
at a certain level
but dude you know me hands are in those
pockets before you [ __ ] get oh my god
i mean there's just i don't know if you
know this but it was
uh i don't know if it was the grammys
or whatever or mtv music i can't
remember grammys or something but tlc
had won
uh i think quite a few awards for
waterfalls or whatever you know for the
for that album i want to say great album
and they uh
you know they gave their speech
and then it's like yeah it's tlc that's
you know they're massive all the stuff
they're doing great
and but they were very honest in that uh
podium
uh speech and exciting speech or
whatever acceptance speech they're like
but we're
broke they're like we have no money
right
you know what i mean it's i mean that
goes back to and they're like that was a
big album
and to that point though that was even
during the time when album sales
mattered and you could actually make
money so that's even worse for that for
that
i'm talking even if you fast forward
that was probably in the 90s right so
you go from the 2000s
early 2000s when everyone really started
to get into napster mp3s yeah everything
like that soon became i mean you start
to get some of your money back now but
we're talking about 20 years
of music musicians and people putting
out music that
haven't really been seen the return that
you used to be able to see or anything
like that and then people complain about
today's music and go like why does
everyone just keep copying and putting
through the same thing because that
keeps working [ __ ] exactly you
keep consuming it that way you're
consuming it as long as you keep
consuming it that way the powers that be
there that are just there for the money
not the actual artists and creators are
going to keep pushing it that way so as
long as they still have a say in it
then that's going to be the way it is
but
there there's a change coming real soon
yeah you know i uh
what i've been noticing a lot today and
i never realized this i've always been a
very big music fan
but didn't obviously didn't know like
the behind the scenes when it comes to a
lot of this stuff with music and it
seems like a lot of people
are
especially artists you know older
artists
um are working their asses off to get
their masters right
you know which i didn't know like that
was a huh some of them are there's also
there's also
it's kind of funny it's it's it's a
tricky thing yeah yeah well
they're not giving the labels are gonna
kick and scream and they're not gonna
give up their masters let's be real
cause it's the only thing that they can
hold on to at this point they don't
distribute anything they don't do
anything they don't do anything anymore
what do they do put it to the radio no
one listens to radio anymore put it in
at a store no one goes to stores anymore
distribution isn't anything anymore what
is what do you need a label for yeah
it's all out there and we're not even
getting into into web 3 yet wait to web
3 comes it's all going to be different
what's web3 you don't know about web3
we'll talk we'll talk about that
um they've learned so much
no i i'm always interested at this stuff
you know because comedy's so different
like
you put out a special but like
it's out there but like no one's like oh
i want to own my
like my well you could because netflix
has a special but you can't really you
can't like so you would have to make a
deal with netflix right now but what if
i were to tell you that you can create
your own stuff and create your own
community and take your jokes clips out
of your jokes or whatever you wanted to
do okay
mint that into a non-fungible token
and sell it to your community and let
them trade around it and they actually
have a piece of your of you
oh
is that what this uh
is that nft thing yes
oh that's what brian brian's been raving
about
because i i don't i don't understand it
now i don't know much i'm not gonna sit
here and pretend like i'm an expert on
it but okay okay um i'm very i'm very
much a layman still i mean you've got to
put in a lot of hours to understand all
this [ __ ] yeah and i have not yet i put
in some not a lot um but what i do know
about it is it's just very exciting
because there it's going to
cut out a lot of middlemen you're gonna
people are gonna be able to go directly
to
their favorite things without being fed
it through an advertisement without
being fed a certain way without 10
million different middlemen in the way
like if if you use it correctly it'll be
another tool don't get me wrong it's not
like it's the end-all everyone's going
to start putting it in your pocket yeah
but it's a tool and it's a it's a
it's a creatively better tool for
artists yeah of of all kinds creators
podcasters
comedians everybody that creates you
know what i mean like you're not going
to have the guy that doesn't create that
just manages you they're just uh yeah
just like i mean and that's great those
they they serve their purpose at a time
when you needed that yeah when you
needed that the times have changed times
have changed there's so much you because
there's so much you can do on your own
like i mean obviously you know because
you you also come from the punk rock
world as well and just music in general
like the diy
mentality
you know it's always been like embedded
in us like since we were like kids but
like now like more more people like it
seems like especially when it comes to
you know creative artists are really
understanding this diy thing right
literally i can do it myself i'll i'll
upload it here yeah and i'll just push
it out like this
what did you say you got a crew here
obviously helping you out a little bit i
got i got my
middleman i'm gonna get rid of you
[ __ ]
no no you still need people
[Laughter]
still need you still need support
systems and stuff but and that's the
other thing is
then your your fan base your community
builds its own community and though that
becomes your support base as well and um
and it just opens up a lot of
opportunities in that way for you and
your fans to interact in that way and
they can actually own pieces trade
pieces
it's it's it's incredible for the fan
too it's not just
a lot of people will look at it go oh
it's just the artists and the creators
wanting more wanting more wanting more
it's not the case at all no it's it's
actually the exact opposite we don't
want to have to feed you [ __ ] we don't
want to have to do all this like dancing
through hoops and everything here you
could own a piece of it and trade it and
now you have something with actual
tangible
uh value yeah in this so every time you
went to buy a cd that used to be value
right it cost you know 10 13
that actually cost something and until
they became obsolete they were actually
worth something people used to sell them
at yard sales just do all that well you
can't do that with uh with a digital
song right now right
but if you were able to get something
some utility behind something that you
purchased from your favorite artist
now you have something that you can use
for the utility that it is whether it be
access to vip tickets when they're on on
the road or something like that
and you now have that
that yeah maybe i don't like this band
in three years yeah
i'm gonna sell it to someone who does
and now at that point maybe that band
has has gone up in its own stock and you
just made money off of it as a fan yeah
i like yeah that's that's pretty dope
because like
you know when i think about it like uh
okay say like i'm a big black flag geek
you know
and
my nephew
is starting in to getting get into black
flag but if i had this piece of black
flag that i could give to him right
that's another just gifting you know if
it's not even for a problem yeah or
probably just like you have this you
know because it's like this new
discovery like that now it's fresh to
you i've had this i know what it's like
it's in it's in my blood now but like
this is like
for you yeah you know what i mean and
and when you think
you
like this middleman thing as well like
at times like yeah you feel like you
know you're listening to these people
and you have to do something that is not
even authentic to you to where
you know
just to like get a connection with fans
and build fans and like without
that's not i don't do that right you
know i kind of want to i don't want to
do that like
to try to build a
fan base i don't want to do it that way
i want to do it
my own way you know what i mean and i
feel like based off what you're saying
and you know correct me if i'm wrong if
i'm outside of this but it seems like
yeah like you could have that
like more of a direct connection
you know and you could do it you're
literally your own way you're and the
community and the community
and you know and you're not you you
can't possibly go off topic on it
because we're still in the new the new
stages of all this this is like this is
still brand new this is still in the
infant stages no one actually really
knows what it's going to look like five
years from now because
then once this really starts to take and
everyone really understands what it
truly is and isn't just some kind of
money grab that they all that a lot of
people not everyone but a lot of people
a lot of people yeah yeah it's it's
really not yeah and once they realize
that the creative people that are
creating these these communities and
these their own metaverses and
everything based on based on this web 3
stuff
it's going to create a creative chain as
well so how are we supposed to know what
it's going to look like in five years
when you might find a really cool way to
use it differently than i do
it's just a tool just like anything else
but it's not it's not
it's not going to be owned and ran by
somebody else you're going to own and
run it yourself yeah
they
oh wow that's pretty dope yeah man i
think about this time when i uh
auditioned for america's got talent and
then no no dishes to anyone that's ever
done it well you i didn't know this
listen
[Laughter]
listen this is what it is that the one
with howard a-g-t
howard who's howard uh stern yes yes yes
but or whatever they do where they
not the not the turnaround thing not the
turnaround he's on that one okay and is
it harry mandel too
yeah i think so i auditioned for that
not live
you know like the
pre-recording auditions right okay for a
stand-up and i remember i went in there
and i remember they gave me this piece
of paper they like asked me like these
questions and they were so
like it was almost like they were trying
to
pull this story
out of me
and i'm not i'm not dissing it that's
what that show does doesn't mean it's
bad that's just what that show does and
that's how that show operates and that's
what makes that show work for itself you
know
but for me and i remember i went in that
audition and they were like asking me
these questions
in a way to where i was just like
this is ugly i don't i don't like this
feeling you know like it was like out
like
almost like i had to be this like
it was just outside of my character
right i didn't feel right right you know
everything and
but but when i when i got the audition i
was like oh okay i can build a fan base
off this you know people are going to
watch this people watch us on tv all
this [ __ ] and then i thought about it i
was like oh that like i have to be this
way
to do that and i was like man that's not
me so i was like i'd rather take this
other route you know and i'm like what
what about me
can i lean into and put out there
that other people are also
you know interested in and care about or
that just gravitates them
towards you know being a fan of you
right you know like that like and i feel
like
you know that's what i just feel like
the
you know when you're an artist like
that's the [ __ ] route like you don't
ever have to [ __ ] do something that
doesn't feel right to you absolutely you
know
to to
make something of yourself i think
everyone can relate to that too not just
artists i mean i mean you gotta
everyone has been in a position where
they're doing something that they don't
necessarily love or they don't
necessarily feel like it's not it's not
for them and i think that's that happens
in every walk of life it just happens to
be for guys like you or myself that's
how we're trying to make money right
yeah so uh in that sense
you want to make money but you also want
to not have to work right
because the old adage is very true you
never have to work a day in your life if
you love what you're doing
so it's like you want that to be the
case how do you make that the case don't
fake the [ __ ] [ __ ] don't forget yeah
yeah and that's what i'm saying like
when i say this because you know i'm not
saying that like oh i'd be that's a
sell-out thing to do americans it's not
even that it's like bro if so if one of
my friends came up to me and said yo i
got an agt audition i'd be like [ __ ]
yeah that's cool man that's cool like i
don't think it's like that but like when
i think about me she probably lacy right
you know what i mean like
and that's that goes to like everything
though yeah i'm saying like
maybe that is what they want like it
works for them you know like uh uh my
friend taylor williamson the comedian
was your friends with taylor yeah yeah
love taylor he's a good dude he's good
he's not taylor i mean and he he just he
did great and he loved it uh yeah he was
on the podcast yeah yeah he's [ __ ]
amazing yeah yeah he did do it he was
the last
was he the very last in person we had
before the pandemic exactly zach was but
okay so uh
he brought kovad with him though taylor
brought covered with him
he comes back
like no joke this is in february before
the [ __ ] happens in in 2020 and he comes
over to the house to do the do the
episode
and he's and he's like man i just got
back from italy i'm i'm feeling better
but like i had this bad cold and i was
coughing and [ __ ] and this was right
when it hadn't made it to america yeah
right but um it had and uh
and uh you know it's funny that because
he's just like he clearly was
really sick really sick yeah and i was
just hit italy heavy oh yeah
it was like two weeks later we heard how
bad italy was i was like
that [ __ ] was just in my house
and this was still like he brought it
back to america that's so funny taylor
brought it back to america
and i remember texting him all like you
[ __ ]
i was like you totally brought kobe to
my house but
it was funny because uh
that was also still at the time when it
was so early and we didn't know what the
[ __ ] was that no one knew what the [ __ ]
it was i was like i mean i hunkered down
i did everything i was supposed to for
like six like for actually majority of
the time until recently like now the
vaccine's out now that everyone's you
know heard mentality is happening or
immunity not mentality
mentality is a different thing that's
how mob's that's a dope band
what's up guys we're heard mentality
get the [ __ ] out
let's do a side project we'll do that
yeah i'll do a side project with you
i'll deal with you a song
song
for that for sure
all right so i do these things called
rapid [ __ ] questions well i never
called it rapid [ __ ] questions okay
he wrote it on there so all right here
we go uh favorite band that's why why do
people do that on a rapid fire question
i'm sorry but you can't ask me my
favorite band on a rapid fire question
it's like
how many [ __ ] bands do i have to
think of before i come up with the
answer but i can say it easy well yeah
you're going to say oasis how did you
know that
my favorite band is not oasis uh no no
easy uh
one that i always fall back on is
metallica
concert
uh
that's tough too though man like my
first concert is a metallica concert but
that might not be my favorite concert
[ __ ] uh
maybe i even throw in the justin
timberlake one on that because that
sounds like that was a really great
concert damn
look you guys i haven't seen him yet
when he when he comes back here or
whatever we'll go we'll we'll [ __ ] go
for sure well well maybe justin will
actually hear this and he'll just yeah
he's actually a big listener so justin
yeah yo hey me and johnny need tickets
going on down to l.a we want all access
passes to this show absolutely we would
be [ __ ] i deserve it
like uh if he did a meet and greet you
know they have their little [ __ ]
little thing you think you think you'd
be able to talk oh background behind
we're both we're both good like we're
just like we can both talk we both have
podcasts can we just be like quiet over
there oh i don't know if i could talk to
him i could you could i could i probably
struggle a little bit
you know there's not i put my foot in my
mouth but i could talk listen there's
not too many people like i geek out over
like i don't like i geek out over
musicians more than i geek out over like
meeting comedians and [ __ ] right
musicians i'm like oh
i geek out over sports guys more oh you
do when i meet sports sports yeah yeah
that's right and i met a couple of
sports people i'm like oh that's cool is
it something that's like so
foreign yeah imagine if you met michael
jordan
i always made the joke and it wasn't
really a joke i was definitely serious
about it that if i ever had the chance i
never had the chance unfortunately to
meet kobe bryant i would just be like if
if he was around i'd just be like i'll
try and play you'll be like whoa i'd be
like this is amazing and let's grab
basketball and just like roll it over to
him and be like you want to say anything
[Laughter]
huge
uh favorite album
oh [ __ ] that's so tough man um again
these are these aren't
that's a rapid fire questions these are
these are tough rapid fire should be
like definitive things that album
band like concert that's too [ __ ]
hard
uh i'll just throw out [ __ ] uh
and outcome the wolves oh hell yeah
great [ __ ] album
that [ __ ] album is so timeless it is
like you listen to it
is amazing too
that was 95 when that when that album
came out yeah and it's [ __ ] like
today sounds so fresh there's nothing
better than opening up us an album with
a song like maxwell murder like that's
that opens the album [ __ ] you win
yep i'm just [ __ ] winning and then
the bass solo the bass says get out of
here i still don't even know what matt
freeman is doing there i've been playing
bass my whole life now
favorite album of your your your band
um
i'd probably go with our self-titled
subtitles yeah we had them i had the
most fun uh creating that record yeah
yeah that was that was a lot of fun that
we were we were all in our early 20s
just experimenting with [ __ ] and just
[ __ ] fine it was super fun uh
favorite favorite concert you've played
no i can't do that i don't [ __ ] know
man
how many concerts have i played i can't
even remember most of them like i don't
know like uh
i'll go back to the metallica thing the
first time we played metallica in europe
that was a so i said let me know when
you figured out that song you guys did
uh
it was a punk song yeah it's a ramone
song
nope still can't remember it so okay
remember yeah hopefully it's online it's
on there somewhat someone can favorite
song to play like i just look it up it's
probably right there but anyways uh
favorite song favorite song to play live
little piece of heaven from the self
title record so we usually play it last
and that i'm usually pretty buzzed by
then and i can have some fun with it you
know oh gosh i just thought of something
from one of you guys's live shows and i
thought i only thought about this
because like with the recent um
travis scott thing there was one time
you guys were doing a show
i'm i'm a nerd and watch live concerts
all the time on youtube that's awesome
and i watch the full [ __ ] concert
there's one time you guys were doing a
festival i want to say in europe might
have been like one of those like
downloads or something like that
and
you guys saw something going on in the
crowd
literally stopped your set walked off
stage until everything was okay and then
came back on what's happening do you
remember that oh it's happening oh god
yeah i don't remember specifically which
one you were watching but yeah i mean
that's happened a few times for us yeah
it's it's it's interesting
yes i mean when i think about the
situation so many people [ __ ] you
know try to dissect and like say this
they say that they say this but i'm like
none of us [ __ ] know the majority of
people that are speaking on it
never played a live concert before
you know what i mean like even with us
doing comedy comedy's not like as big as
like
a festival well and even still like i
mean correct me if i'm wrong you're not
getting circle pits going white for you
[Laughter]
that would be the opposite [ __ ] joke
that would be rad you should totally do
that should totally do the next step
like this i want to see you
[ __ ] go crazy for this joke
right here
this one's gonna [ __ ] slay your mind
that would be so much fun that would be
[ __ ] hilarious i i would i would pay
a lot of money to see that comedian dude
you should be the one to do it just
[ __ ] get the circle pick going
forward or if someone's already done it
before i don't know uh well they haven't
done it as well as you can yeah i could
probably pull it off pretty good yeah
but back to that like i mean that's
happened several times where like for us
um
to my memory most of the times it's been
either someone's might have passed out
from sun exhaustion or something during
the day more often than not someone in
the pit
um
and some of those pits are on cement you
fall down you crack your head you know
so
usually someone will get it get our
attention and we'll stop playing for a
minute so the ambulance could get in
because you're going through a swarm of
people you gotta let everyone know okay
everyone chill out for a second it's
gonna take a minute for someone to get
in there and grab this guy get him out
as far as like the travis scott things
goes like everyone's talking about it
obviously or they were a month ago um
i totally don't
it sucks because that's not travis
scott's fault at all there's no everyone
can look at it like you're saying who's
never been on that side of the stage is
like we should have known what was going
on
dude you don't know if his eyes were
open you had sunglasses on those lights
in your eyes like you cannot see past a
first couple of rows you just can't
you're playing at night there's lights
all in your face that is true because
even at comedy shows we can only see
like
the first row yeah and then add on
sunglasses because you're vibing out and
on you're singing a lot of people who
aren't wearing sunglasses you'll see
famous singers closing their eyes when
they're going for [ __ ] you know like
really feeling it
they're in there you're in your world
like yeah you know because you're trying
to deliver you're trying to think about
the performance you're delivering yeah a
lot of times and that that's making an
assumption about how he gets down too i
don't really know yeah but i from my
experience there's you can't you can't
see everybody in the in the crowd
especially a crowd that size that he was
playing
you can't you can't blame somebody like
that that's what that's what like i'd
rather talk to him you know someone
that's like actually played something of
that caliber you know like that you know
to that many people because a lot of
people when i hear them talk about it
i'm just like you know you don't
we've never played we've never played a
[ __ ] big ass concert like that and
like i wouldn't even compare doing
comedy shows yeah to that at all because
it's so small and people are sitting
down looking up at you you know what i
mean like so it's it's it's like
i just hear so many people talk about it
in ways as if they truly [ __ ] know
well and i'm like i'd rather that's a
problem with society right now that's
yeah everyone thinks they know
everything and it's like it's great to
be knowledgeable about a lot of things
but stop pretending stop saying things
as facts when you don't actually know if
they're yes people a lot of times people
think their world is the world exactly
it's like [ __ ] knows that that's and
that's natural
that's natural but stop pretending like
you know
because you don't and that's the whole
thing like and it's clear that you don't
have a scott [ __ ] done this year that's
like ed it is absolutely can be we just
admit that we don't know [ __ ] yeah i
admit i
i i admit all the time i don't know [ __ ]
i never heard of that no absolutely and
i'm comfortable with [ __ ] saying that
because i was because i don't want to be
that [ __ ] guy like yeah yeah that's
[ __ ] yeah that was when they did and
i'm like
just what i'm gonna be honest with like
i don't [ __ ] know that i don't
[ __ ] know and then
because i mean that's the other thing is
then it becomes displaced like it's on
travis scott because he's the name and
everything's like no that was the
[ __ ] idiots in the back that was
people in a mob mentality back to
mentality go and go back going back and
let's point the blame at where really
get where where the public yeah it was
the public you don't wanna you gotta
find one person it's like no it's not
always one person yeah it's you guys got
a bomb mob mentality going and you
[ __ ] up a couple people doing it like
that sucks but
take take the [ __ ] blame take the
[ __ ] blame don't push it on someone
and then go like that guy needs to be
sued that's ridiculous it's absolutely
ridiculous you do that [ __ ] right you're
going to keep going down this rabbit
hole you're never going to see concerts
again i know
that better not happen i'll be [ __ ]
heated uh so i like to do this thing
where i call it like basically the
soundtrack to the episode and basically
i like to create create a playlist with
each guest okay at the end we'll do 10
to 12 songs and we just spit fire off
and
mainly the playlist is just the vibe of
the episode right you know and so uh my
my producer filled me in on that before
he came over oh he didn't drop up and
he's like hey just so you know there's
gonna be playlists at the end just so
you don't like give him a bunch of dead
air i was like i don't know man let's
just go
oh but before we get into that yeah uh
we brought you a goodie bag
oh i get goodies yeah yeah man no one
ever
man to all my other guests that have
been on here eat a dick i'm just kidding
just kidding
don't tell me to dick no cause i loved
you guys you guys were great guys not as
good as this there's some drinks with
johnny [ __ ] in there oh yeah you put
wild turkey turkey in there i i should
have
if i knew you were back on the wagon
or is it i don't know it's like the
worst thing for people
oh this is amazing you won't open an
hour or no yeah go for it man oh really
yeah
if you i mean unless you want unless you
feel no this is fine no i don't care man
my birthday's coming up anyway happy
birthday
i knew that
i [ __ ] knew that
let's see what we got oh this is special
that's the special part actually
you want me to wait for the special part
then you can [ __ ] open it uh this
this man over here sam made this for you
i've been seeing this a little as
chappelle's world action figure
and you got the black flag windbreaker
correct
yeah sam sam just started doing this
where's the camera i can put it at
is this my camera that's your camera
this is my johnny carson camera
this is [ __ ] amazing and you got like
chapelle squad checklist he was printing
up that cardboard at my house last night
you what this is [ __ ] insane he did
all that he'll tell you all about it
after after we stopped the cameras i
forgot to put you guys
now [ __ ] them
this is magical yeah that's [ __ ]
staying in here for sure
we got we got to get that hung up you
know what i'm saying over here we got
some
avenged sevenfold
oh [ __ ] yeah i like those i love this
logo by the way thank you because i love
skulls and i like that you add the
[ __ ] bat wings to it yeah man
i'm a big oh i'm gonna get drunk off
this tonight see again yeah just kidding
i'm just kidding
but but you can pour wild turkey in and
just leave it just leave it yeah
you know that's what i'm gonna do i'm
gonna have it here but you're gonna need
more wild turkey because you won't you
won't realize it but if you pour
something in there like that and leave
it it will evaporate so you're gonna
have to keep buying wow yeah i'll have
to keep buying it yeah yeah
but keep them in business i know it's so
funny about that
a fan spots me buying wild turkey
they're like oh are you okay
that's just a bandana oh bandana oh good
cause i'm gonna need this for this
[ __ ] tough murder murder
uh murder tough murder are you doing a
mud run yeah [ __ ] stupid
gosh i [ __ ]
i'm so [ __ ] bad why did you agree
because i said it as a joke and then all
of a sudden i'm [ __ ] doing it
gosh i'm not excited for that damn thing
you know i need to get i'm sorry i need
to get my david goggins on and [ __ ]
stay hard
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] coffee mug yep can't go wrong
with a coffee mug
this is awesome
some drinks with johnny's shirts yeah
and yeah that's pretty much more shirts
oh yeah more shirts no i don't have any
[ __ ] gifts for you see why you do
that now i got to feel like i got to get
you something well next time you come on
my show i'm going to
in person i'll drink all the wild turkey
for you yeah just do that yeah yeah but
i would like to do it in person yeah
come on down are you gonna be down at
the rec room anytime soon no but i
[ __ ] love that room that's a cool
place i know i need to hit uh kenny uh
you know give oh yeah have one of these
coasters all right
i love these costumes
it makes me feel bad about my coaster
i have coasters as well but like they
don't they're not like they're made out
of cardboard i don't know what that's
made out of granite
i mean it's made out of something nice
it's something nice what is the way to
you gotta we put uh we put a qr code on
it though you gotta put a qr code on it
so that people could scan it and find
your podcast oh gosh i'm gonna hit this
guy over marketing [ __ ] don't hit me up
i'm not very good at
exactly don't
all right so uh uh playlist uh playlist
i'll do
i'll do misfits death comes ripping
right so we're talking about stuff that
we you know things that we talked about
in it yeah we can do things we talked
about or whatever
we were talking a lot about i think
metallica came up a few times so i'll
put battery
in there battery that's a good one i
love that song damn
damn
stumped him i know
are we going we're supposed to be going
back and forth uh
yeah can i join the targets on
yeah
i'll do uh motor breath oh that's a
great one i love that one
good one i love that i love that album
that i'm so good that album [ __ ]
for me that was one of the things when
we were talking about picking up the
bass for the first time was listening to
cliff burton do anastasia pulling teeth
on that record that was
pretty pretty r.p cliff man all right we
got uh
we talked about some punk rock and i
talked about how hoss
changed changed my life
so we'll go with the first track off
that which was uh new messiah i believe
i'll do
we'll throw a curveball at people i'll
do justin timberlake oh
[Music]
i'll do crimey river oh that's a great
one i'll do that one off justified
yeah see that was good now
now i want to do it justice checking out
the [ __ ] uh
future sex love songs just like love
songs that i mean
i did not stop listening to that album
when it finally my love
my love so i went as justin
all right i'm going to go i'm going to
do it jt my love oh here i knew us yeah
so quick story on that uh that summer
i've never met him yet
you know
fun story on that actually yeah
i was told by uh our guitar sinister
gates not to go say hi to him when i was
inebriated he was at he was at the same
hotel as us in the hotel lobby he was we
were having a
drink at the bar and he rolls up
at the other end of the bar
and he's just like
being just a nice guy you know someone
had their dog in there i think he was in
new york or some [ __ ] so my other dog is
petting the dog oh this dog's so sweet
and i'm like that's [ __ ] justin
timberlake i'm gonna go buy him a drink
and i started seeing him he's all you're
too drunk dude you're gonna put your
foot in your mouth you could put your
foot in your mouth i was like he's like
just don't do it i was like [ __ ]
when am i ever going to get this up
i didn't do it
and i'm still pissed at brian dude i
would have just done it i should have i
would those this was a few years ago and
i wasn't the confident man that i am now
yeah but uh
no i'm gonna reach out to justin in some
way i did you should and like and when
he comes on this when he comes on the
show you'll you'll do it with me
absolutely
wherever i'm at i'll fly out
yeah you're about to walk on stage i
want to tell you one story i think you
remember when you're at that bar and
there's that dog and i think you might
have been a little high i couldn't tell
but uh you were really nice to that dog
i was going to buy you a bottle of wine
but i didn't do that cool story bro
no and then that when my love came out
that summer it was like the biggest song
of that summer and then october came
around and for halloween i went as
justin timberlake from that video
i'll send you a picture of it i think i
need that picture i think i did a pretty
good job uh so we did you did my love
i'll do
i talked about offspring i'll do
offspring bad habit um
it's a good one i used to love cranking
that song yeah
because you know it was in the when that
song was popular i was getting driven
around by my mother i couldn't drive
myself so i used to love that's like the
perfect song to drive around too with
your mom
[ __ ]
felt so cool
back to punk though let's do uh we're
talking about outcome the wolves yeah we
did maxwell we talked about maxwell
murder but
another one
it's the obvious one is ruby soho ruby
soho that video was like at a time when
music videos were played
it was an independent one made by
epitaph records yep very simple music
video but was played all the time on mtv
when it was that's a good one
it was really cool so rancid uh ruby
soho
and there's a ruby soho that comes out
to that song in aew if you're a
wrestling fan
really oh yeah yeah yeah she used to be
ruby wright in the wwe now she's ruby's
mars is a big wrestling uh fan as well
yeah absolutely yeah lars came on my
podcast last season oh he did yeah we
talked for about we released an hour and
45 minutes of it we talked for about two
and a half hours about wrestling we
didn't you talk about
he's amazing i just uh
i met him well we met online uh
not like a dating app or anything
[Laughter]
i would love to see that ticket of lars
just like [ __ ] pissed
swipe right yeah yeah
no he uh
i got a rancid tattoo oh [ __ ] and he uh
uh
i tagged like granted and stuff like
that and the crew
and uh he uh started following me and we
started chopping it up or whatever but i
have met he's tim armstrong and
i've been able to like jam with him
that's rad i've met him a couple of
times on the warped tour he's always
been a nice dude the nicest [ __ ] guy
he's a great dude such a great guy he's
got he's got his
studio out here he's got his own studio
out here does he know yeah yeah i think
he bought it from i think he said he
brought from maybe flea or something
like that oh [ __ ] yeah so
that was another great concert too i saw
with uh
when uh
when he was married uh the distillers
opened it up and then it was afi and
rancid at the hollywood palladium at the
palladium that sounds like a dope show
it was insane it was so rad it was my
first introduction to afi actually
really yeah
they're they're i think they're back on
the road now too that would be awesome
to see um so how many we got does this
playlist usually take this long no not
cool
just wanted to make sure i'm breaking
records no you're right you're rigging
all the records
i know about nfts no one's ever taught
me that
i've been learning uh you did ransom
ruby soho
i'll do um
you brought up uh no effects
yeah i'll do
the shout out to that mike in his
podcast yeah shout out to fat mike he's
he's a good dude he's so much fun he's
so bad
i'll do no effects uh
let's do the bruise
yeah let's do that
and i'll by the way i love smelly smells
i met him uh recently
amazing guys he's a [ __ ] he's he's like
he lives out your way i think yeah he
lives in long beach he's not far he's
lives
he's right around the corner from our
drummer brooks and i had i had smelly on
the show as well it's funny enough like
had like all these guys on my phone yeah
besides justin coming on soon
[Laughter]
and uh we're such geeks
no one's gonna believe it
i know right
what am i thinking you know you need to
get be even like creepier about it
though if you're gonna do it and
photoshop yourself next to justin and
put it up
[Laughter]
or better yet like like you were like
you met the entire in sync crew like
like put you in like when they're like
celebrating one of their platinum
records instead of the label guy just
put you let me there's like
how many is that casey that's nine i
believe all right one more you'll top it
off oh [ __ ] who else well we're talking
punk rock but we didn't bring up one of
my favorites in the descendants uh yeah
the cool the bu record was huge for me
um
one more day uh it was an amazing song
that i listened to
uh every every
time before we played our last warped
tour yeah we listened to cool to be you
in the bus to get pumped up before you
got the best you got the best of both
worlds yeah like growing up and [ __ ]
just all that like well not the best of
both worlds a lot of worlds musically
yeah you know a lot of people miss it
but you know because everyone thinks
about hollywood and and acting but
southern california is crazy for music
too you get crazy from music you get
everything every [ __ ] thing everyone
yeah you wouldn't you wouldn't expect a
lot of country
stations one more day
one more day yeah sorry
it's a very heartfelt song too that
wasn't a joke that is a very hardcount
song
well yeah i just say it sometimes like
even my wife's like i could never tell
when you're serious or being sarcastic
and like neither can that's what's funny
about you like you're you have a very
comedic you know timing and style well
that means a lot coming from yeah yeah
yeah no you really do i know someone in
most base and they do the [ __ ] most
bass players are quiet there's there's
some loud bass players out there oh yeah
anyways johnny christ everybody uh check
out his podcast uh drinks with johnny uh
which you drop what every week every
monday every monday
and uh on youtube we'll be kicking those
back up right now we're in between
seasons right now yeah and i i bank a
few because i got other [ __ ] to do um
but we will do season four will be on
youtube every every monday but right now
the audio we're doing like a bunch of
best dubs right now which is really cool
okay yes i'm going back and like we did
best of wrestling and i'm like holy [ __ ]
i've had like a lot of really cool pro
wrestlers on my show it's just cool
because it's just a fun thing for me to
do so when i actually look back at what
you do best of comedians yeah well that
one's coming buddy you're gonna be on
that one
i made it
thank you for coming by thanks for
coming out thank you yeah
you